région de kiev les corps s'entassent
dans les morgues déjà plus de mille
vingt civils retrouvés morts sylvain
rousseau bonjour vous êtes grand
reporter sur france 24 vous êtes de
retour de kiev vous avez pu vous rendre
au nord de la capitale dans les villes
martyres de borodianka de boudhha là où
des dizaines de cadavres ont été
retrouvés dans les rues aujourd'hui ces
villes s'en débarrasser des russes mais
anéanti oui absolument encore neuf
cadavres ont fait les autorités
ukrainiennes en tout cas on communiquait
sur la découverte de neuf cadavres à
nouveau aujourd'hui dans la ville de
bourg odien caire neuf cadavres de
civils qui portent des traces de torture
il faut savoir que dans toutes ces
villes borodianka butch haïr pin là les
paysages sont les mêmes les immeubles
des sondés des immeubles qui sont
ravagés éventré calcinés et on voit des
gens qui reviennent petit à petit dans
ces immeubles alors évidemment pas pour
y vivre c'est impossible mais pour
ramasser chez eux ce qui ce qui peut
encore l'être et nous avons pu suivre
l'une de ces familles qui repartaient
avec quelques couvertures avec des
vêtements avec une telle est également
qui a miraculeusement survécu aux
bombardements alors que c'était
probablement l'objet le le plus fragile
de la maison mais ce qui frappe quand on
rentre dans ses appartements c'est
l'odeur on est plus d'un mois après les
frappes sur sur l'immeuble donc et nous
avons pénétré et on sentait encore une
odeur âcre une odeur de brûlé qui
s'imprégnait sur nos vêtements qui ne
qui nous prenaient le le nez la gorge
mais au delà de au delà de ces
destructions le plus terrible ce sont
les témoignages des gens qui sont restés
pendant cette occupation russe
puisqu'ils dans chaque village il y a
des gens qui n'ont pas pu fuir qui sont
restés et les témoignages font état de
tortures de viols de meurtres est très
difficile à entendre sur des femmes sur
des hommes des adolescents des enfants
et même des bébés rendez vous compte et
alors pour ça il ya des preuves quand
même puisque certains soldats russes
n'ont rien trouvé de mieux à faire que
de se filmer pendant qu'il commettait
ses crimes donc pour ça que ça reste
quand même quelque chose de documenter
mais le plus compliqué maintenant pour
les enquêteurs c'est justement de
recueillir ces témoignages et
d'identifier les soldats russes les
victimes évidemment beaucoup beaucoup de
mal ne veulent pas forcément
parler mais les autorités ukrainiennes
affirme déjà avoir identifié 200 soldats
russes coupables de ces exactions voilà
pour ce qui est autour de kiev que se
passe-t-il dans le centre-ville de qui
elle vit encore des bombardements alors
les bombardements reprenait lorsque nous
nous partions de kiev c'est à dire en
fin de semaine et début de semaine
notamment en réponse à la taxe sur le
moskva le navire amiral dans la mer
noire ou encore au bombardement attribué
aux ukrainiens par moscou de deux
villages frontaliers et effectivement on
a pu voir que les bombardements
reprenait est essentiellement sur des
usines de d'armement ou des dépôts de
munitions on sait aussi que la défense
anti aérienne ukrainienne protègent la
ville lorsque nous y étions c'est que
deux missiles qui était destiné au
centre ville de kiev ont été arrêtés par
la défense antiaérienne et c'est pour ça
effectivement que les autorités
demandent aux gens de ne pas revenir
trop vite à kiev même si on la noue on a
pu constater sur place la vie reprend
lentement mais d'abord les points
d'accès sont extrêmement limité
puisqu'ils ont été détruits de
l'approvisionnement est compliqué y
compris pour l'aide humanitaire et puis
effectivement on a peur que a selon
comment ça se passe dans l'est du pays
vladimir poutine fasse abattre un déluge
de feu sur la capitale ukrainienne et on
demande effectivement aux gens de
attendre encore un peu avant de rentrer
parce que les combats se poursuivent
ailleurs on en parle beaucoup plus de 7
7 millions de déplacés à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine et puis il y as haute cette
autre chiffre 1 qui cache une horreur
une horrible réalité 5 millions
d'ukrainiens ont quitté le pays on a
atteint les 5 millions on a atteint les
5 millions effectivement alors nous nous
avons pu rencontrer quelques-uns de ces
réfugiés à lviv la grande ville de
l'ouest du pays c'est la plaque
tournante des réfugiés puisque ceux qui
vont en pologne passez par là ils ont
aussi beaucoup qui reste dans cette
région vous l'avez souligné les déplacer
alors quand on a demandé aux autorités
de vivre si elle pouvait encore absorber
ce flot de réfugiés qui continuent
d'arriver continuellement de l'est du
pays elles se sont voulues rassurantes
et nous ont dit que la région était
grande ils ont réquisitionner des
gymnases des stades même de foot parfois
des universités pour pouvoir loger un
maximum de gens et puisqu'on a pu voir à
lviv aussi et bien ce
effectivement ces réfugiés qui arrivait
et puis d'autres qui croisaient en fait
ceux qui rentraient chez eux qui
commençaient à rentrer notamment dans la
région de kiev puisque les russes
venaient de quitter cette région merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
sylvain rousseau